clark county is offering bonuses to try  and help small businesses find new hires  about a hundred small businesses were at  a job fair today at the world market  center those who are hired will get 500  bonuses after a month on the job the  money is coming from the county and  cities the county says it recognizes  that the job market is tight right now  and small businesses can't always offer  what big ones can  not everybody needs to work for a casino  or work for a large employer small  employers small businesses  are actually a large part of our economy  so we just want to make sure that they  get the support that they need  the fair featured more than 100 local  employers and spots for people to do  interviews or even touch up their  resumes